people have very strong conceptions
I'll explain you also August
in English what do I refuse that if you
invest a single penny also in startup
you will become 100x from here or become
zero welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Jeet chandan an
experienced entrepreneur and founder he
is a marketing Maestro and a fintech
specialist who's created a legacy in the
entrepreneurial World by working with
the vision of bringing changes to the
ever evolving planet with the aim to
join entrepreneurs and businesses with
the idea of new orders GT has built
significant platforms like entromax
bizdate app and short gun
[Music]
and welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you for being here how are you
I'm great how are you
good good where are you calling from
right now
so I am based out of Bombay which is in
India right now and yeah
wonderful and so you've been involved
very heavily involved with the tech
ecosystem in India as an investor as an
entrepreneur tell me a little bit about
your own background in the Indian
ecosystem and and what got you started
into this whole world yourself
okay so people that are successful
encourage others to follow in their
footsteps so I would love to take
example of my dear Dad uh Mr Mukesh and
then uh so he helped me a lot to change
my thought process uh in what kind of
thoughts I had to come into example
where I was very small at the age of 10
12 my dad used to always tell me about
Mr Mukesh Ambani and Mr written Tata and
many other inspiration leaders uh he
taught me the basics and the core of
core values of business even my uncle Mr
vikra who taught me how business has to
be done so both of them had has played a
very supporting role in my
entrepreneurial Journey so when I was 13
I created my first mobile app uh so the
mobile app was truly a social media kind
of an app for a community when I was 16
uh it's not something new but I started
and uh NGO known as
Foundation
so basically help run Foundation was an
NGO one of the first kind where we used
to make people self-residental
self-sustainable means uh self-reliant a
person who get generated income on their
on himself example do you know the
condition of India also there are many
farmers there are many people who are at
an unemployed in India so what we used
to do we used to give them jobs or
business plans and business in India
where they could earn minimum 10 000
rupees 20 000 rupees in India which
helped success in their lives so when
covet came I came to one way back uh so
when I came to Bombay like every
youngster I was also into Netflix Amazon
Prime and all of the series but after a
point my dad told me now you have to
become serious that time my age was only
20 18 so I mean so my age is only 18 and
my dad told me I have to become serious
so I thought we are I have to do
something online in my life
so I started my own digital marketing
company as a software company a within
six months of time I started earning a
lot so which I thought that I should
start investing in other startups
because to grow my money I can take
risks today and grow uh the funds I have
so I started investing in one standard
five startup State 10 startups and later
on we started a brand known as base data
uh base data was basically a platform uh
in USA and it's really famous for
crowdfunding platform so we have created
a very uh well-known crowdfunding
platform in India which helps startup
invest their investments in different
kind of startups
and here I am uh with you sitting on the
podcast and explaining how I'm doing
business and this is how my journey has
been it was not difficult but I had some
different kinds of struggles uh in terms
of convincing how a small 20 year old
boy can raise money was the most
difficult part for me to even explain my
parents even explain my colleagues and
even explain my employees and these
three things have earned me a lot
because convincing anyone for anything
was becoming so difficult at a point
which I decided that I have to do it and
I did it at this point yeah wow and so
what what happened after that six month
Mark which told you okay now I'm
transitioning from
from focusing on on earning the money to
now reinvesting it that's it's not a
trick it's not a trivial
um transition what what led to that for
you
okay so basically that was not difficult
because my family background was really
strong so I did not have any Financial
obstacles okay to do something this for
my family I had to
so here I was as an entrepreneur I was
secured him so I could totally focus on
my business and I could take whatever
kind of risk I want if I had to play
someone in crypto if I had to bet on any
of the startups even the most riskiest
of the things I'm vetted on so
immediately where we invest in is early
stage startups like where they are
building the nvp whether the language
will be built or not built the money
which we are raising will be raised the
money which I am investing will be
invested and the risk is almost hundred
percent it's not there if the product is
built then only I'm investing If the
product is not even built I bet on the
founders I bet on the integrity and I
bet if this becomes true
it's successful no I tell you just a
small idea it's really fascinating for
me when we invested there so it was an
idea where you can charge an electric
vehicle in 30 seconds
do you think it's true
like it sounds difficult right so in
India
so I have invested about uh 25 30 lakh
rupees in that startup in India itself
let's start up right now has built the
channel maybe recently one month back
where it can charge any electric vehicle
in 30 seconds
so that's the kind of outputs you are
getting we have to build better the
founders bet on their integrity and your
viewers
and so
also the decision to make it more of a
crowdfunding and to make it more
accessible to you know to people around
and you only go through the website part
of it is also you know the small amount
that you have to invest in order to be a
part of the ecosystem where does that
come from that that thesis
is going to grow tremendously so by that
statistics the poor Capital Income will
also increase people are going to invest
in crypto also people are going to
invest in stock market also so why not
startups if people who can invest in
crypto I don't say crypto is wrong but
crypto is something which you can't see
if people can invest in crypto which is
an underlying technology then why not in
startups startups are something which
are built on the removes which is
something you can watch you can see
everyday growth it's like it's not based
on someone's demand and Supply whereas
crypto is basically magically based on
the demand Supply and the technology and
the community but these kind of startups
are basically based on the Technology
based on their Trader based on the
marketing based on multiple Solutions
which India is requiring now and which I
believe that startups have a great
future in India there are many startups
who are in losses there are many
services in profits and there are many
startups which are growing continuously
in India what I thought why not and
Retail investor or a small investor like
every one of us should get a chance to
invest in India because everyone can't
invest five lakhs 10 lakhs 20 lakhs 30
lakhs right so everyone should get a
chance to invest in India that was my
vision
tell me a little bit more about about
India as a startup ecosystem from your
familiar lens yeah you're choosing to
invest in India and obviously it's an
emerging market with
so many so much Innovation so much crazy
things happening tell me a little bit
about what you're observing around here
okay so I'll start doing some basics in
it so two years back when I was in
Bangalore The Hub of startups uh I made
an auto rickshaw person take care so he
was an engineer a software engineer so
what he used to do so from morning to
evening he used to work at his office in
Wipro evening he used to come at home he
used to drive Rickshaw Like Richard Auto
automobile vehicle he used to start at
riding Rickshaw till late uh till late
till 12 o'clock and one day I came
across him and I spoke to him he why are
you doing this you have a good salary
good package and why are you driving
Rickshaw so what he thought told me that
in job I am earning approximately 40 000
rupees per one and by driving this
Rickshaw half a day I get 20 25 000
bucks
so getting the point and he told me that
I have this idea and I want to build
this and I have to raise some funds for
that
so I was understanding in Bangalore in
cities like Bangalore if people have a
mindset of Entrepreneurship then that
said that what will all people putting
the people in a diet and dry these
videos do
you understanding right
people and tired to other cities will
grow tremendously in India so I'll give
you some time to buy three example also
so entire two basically the startup
ecosystem is going to be tremendously so
I have my two incubation sectors uh in
meerut and Jaipur right now we are
planning to get approximately 50 more in
the next six months wow with my startup
business uh basically the incubation is
going to help the startups raise funds
to grow their Investments and to help
them a hand holding support with mentors
and other Solutions
so like companies like Cola somato
people think that they don't have a
future but people don't know that there
are so much of communities they have so
much of people who have invested in
zomato right so every day I use for my
talking if I want to order food I use
zomato I want to travel without my
driver I have to go with hula only I
feel they are more safe they are more
secure and they are all convenient and
unhabituated so when they started they
were giving their production free
that was a strategy to adapt the market
fast now their charge has 50 rupees 100
rupees 150 rupees for delivery shot two
kilometers only
in USA the Lord might be very small but
as Indians these amounts are very loud
at a very grandson for us
basically the Indian setup custom
basically what I understand is very easy
to understand
there are four routes of it one is
conception people have very strong
conceptions
in English what do I refuse that if you
invest a single penny also in startup
you will become 100x from here or become
zero and that's true to a certain point
of extend you all Channel as an investor
if you invest any point of money or if
you invest a thousand dollars one
million dollars or ten million dollars
you might lose it totally oil become or
it will become 30 x 50 x 100x and that's
true for all of us but uh the Poetry
ecosystem in startups like companies
like zerotha
have been totally profitable in India
it's a billion dollar unicorn right now
company which took minimum five to ten
years today but it was very strongly
rooted from its Finance okay that we
don't have to go in the market and start
spending money to get consumers when we
built a strong product transcription
and every every year zeroda has booked
profits not given a single year in
xenoda was a mass making and right now
due to the trusting Market changes the
recession coming soon in the USA India
everywhere in every country shows me
that investment in startups might reduce
analytically but I would like to tell
you that today also in India Investments
are happening at a very high Pace there
are not much news coming out of the
market but there is a very high scope in
India for Investments also right now
when the market is going down people are
thinking that I should put in real
estate Commodities and startups people
are not thinking of two people are
thinking of stock market people are only
thinking investing real estate gold or
starters
why startups you know
because there are many startups who are
either profitable but that about honored
every business starting in India is a
startup today example I I leave this
business if I'm doing a job I leave this
business I go ahead I can also do a
startup you get you can start your own
startup you cannot just I want to race
so every new business is starting to
start up whether it's profitable loss
making you raise or not raise does not
make any sense every business static in
India start every month in India people
have registered more than 20 000 firms
it means every year we are having more
than one lakh entrepreneurs and with my
aim with my incubation Pace I would love
to contribute every year more than 50
000 entrepreneurs by next year itself so
right now this month only is added to
incubation centers every month you have
a plan of Starting around 2 you can
build centers
wow so then it's incredible
So the plan is if we incubate startups
entire two Tire three tired to buy three
basically means Villages of India so if
we incubate good entrepreneursion there
and if they revised well they grow well
the system of India will grow example
there is a lot of unemployment and the
problem on a of unemployment nor with Mr
Mukesh Armani can solve history
or not any fds games on the only solving
unemployment can be done by startups
because the more number of entrepreneurs
will grow India grow in India the more
the business is improve yeah
right and so take me back a little bit
towards where this personal passion of
yours is coming from creating this sort
of butterfly effect in the sexual growth
where is that coming from for you
okay so basically people would like to
work in that company or me because I
believe in empowering DP and uh I uh I'm
basically getting empowered from Mr
Sandeep maheshpuri from Mr bindra so you
know what happens when I when we watch
different kinds of videos when we watch
different kinds of entrepreneurs to
different multiple days we also feel
that how I can do different how I can
get impact to the society so there was a
time when I used to see many poor people
uh begging on the streets in India and I
thought why I should be or what I can do
for them should I give them money I have
500 rupees in my pocket I can give them
that but will that solve their problem
no right or they need to be guided well
right that time I started udon and from
hold on I got the roots of how
entrepreneurship should be taken care of
and I took a decision that with Udan I
am getting these Villages and these
people
employed so with my journey of
Entrepreneurship can't I get the people
who have studied well people who have
done engineering people have done other
kinds of studies who are not getting
jobs get them to entrepreneurship
because if they talked about the
pressure they have lots of energy
because of not getting job because of
not doing multiple they are already
frustrated and if I give them some
opportunity what will happen they'll
boost up and that was the biggest Theory
like two and a half backs I thought that
because of this and if I do this I might
get successful here might make hundreds
of people successful with that see this
is something more only for Ernie not
from a brand but but this is something
which I had from my use before even
starting this data for long-term acts I
had thought that I would do something
for them and this is what kind of
contribution I want
wow take me to your grander vision for
yourself what are you what are you
excited to be working on what do you
wish to be working on over the years
so basically I want to walk to the
YouTube
and I want to make sure if the
government does something or not I want
to make sure that there should be every
person in India who should have their
own dead and bite their own hard work
you came to India you saw some poor
person and gave them money I don't want
to seal that I want to see every Indian
earn their bread and butter from their
own hard work I know there will be
losses there will be depression there'll
be multiple other problems too but
I have a vision not everyone but
majority will do that at the time
because if you are if you are earning I
am earning the country's economy is
going then every development will also
take place every new business will also
take basically new employment will also
take place if we say India is seeing a 5
trillion dollar economy in next seven to
eight years then why not I contribute to
that economy
why I can't get so many youngsters so
many alternation that business like
recently only with my platform are
funded more than five startups in one
month
if I go by this space Also every year I
will create more than 100 entrepreneurs
only with my funding platform if I also
incubate this with my incubation
platform I might create more than 1000
entrepreneurs by this year end
there's a thing is if I clean thousands
on the mouse every Entertainer gets
around two or three jobs and giving 3000
jobs a year which is known as the Mukesh
Amaria hiring some people for his
company for a month type
right my only vision is key everyone
should have their own brand me your name
maybe a billionaire or we do anything
does not make any sense
today I will do or someone else will
contribute to India it may be you it may
be some other entrepreneur but something
this is what I want to contribute if I'm
online yeah
amazing amazing man so how are you
getting people around you to to build
that Vision with you where how do you
draw them in how do you even draw them
into this greater Vision are they
specifically in the vision of a business
adopt what what how how do you get them
riled up for this so basically there are
two parts of it if I'm getting any
employ on board I don't speak much about
my vision because uh I know that till
that till a long time example if you are
not working with me for more than six
months eight months or one year or the
employer never comes close to me because
there is a policy with me that I should
not be sharing all my vision all my
ideas to everyone right so what we do my
only poor committee or core management
of the company the co-directors only
know about Envision and I have already
convinced them like nobody is taking
salaries
foreign
also working with me there are some
youngsters who are already hnis or you
can call them already at a very good
phase working with me and no we're not
paying them salaries you're not paying
them to parents they know that much
right results also and they're working
for us because they believe in me
basically I have made them Trust on me
that why we should do this together why
you should collaborate with me and why
you should come with me and that's the
one point
I love it Jeet I really want to thank
you for coming here sharing with me
these 20 minutes sounds like you're
working on some really amazing
initiatives and uh with the greater with
the big vision for what you're doing now
and even greater vision for what you're
doing later on and uh thank you for very
much for the time and for the energy and
best of luck
oh thank you Michael oh I just want to
conclude this meeting okay I'm really
happy to have this podcast with you and
I just want to tell you that we should
collaborate somewhere all the other
because I have radio profiling than
everything else and I feel we have some
penology syncology together right
would love to would love to thank you
very much yeah thank you
[Music]